New York is cool and all but [ __ ] is it
noisy
and noise
I'm gonna challenge myself to turn the
noisy streets into the four main genres
of music that make up New York City just
me my camera and a hell of a lot of
songs
this video was brought to you by
storyblocks but I'll tell you more about
them later
foreign
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
NYC
I came from the families that's a fact
me and my brothers
NYC
Les
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
New York like I've never experienced it
before
I just finished editing this Mammoth of
an edit however I did have some help and
that helped with storyblocks which makes
the entire production process post uh
shooting everything so much faster how
you ask well in this case when I gave
myself one day to try and shoot the four
different genres with diegetics and
video which is just ridiculous I knew
that I was going to need some help even
though I I got pretty close I used
storyblocks new editing tool for
Premiere Pro you can download any stock
file straight to your project directly
from storyblocks unlimited royalty free
demand driven Library boom just like
that it's pretty incredible and I'm
honestly really Blown Away with the
sheer amount of stock footage like I was
able to find people playing trumpets in
New York City I was able to find people
dancing but if you don't believe me
click on the link below and check it out
sign up today for one of the flexible
subscriptions using the link below and
yeah other than that don't forget euros
and brew and I'll see you next week
see
[Music]
NYC
me and my brothers be chilling I'm
trying to get the money trying to do
what I do
[Music]